entre escombros y destrucción es como
viven muchos ciudadanos en Siria tras
los terremotos la ciudad costera de ya
hablé bajo el control del gobierno sirio
las personas no han sufrido tanto los
estragos de la guerra pero el seísmo los
ha asumido en la miseria allí entre
4.000 y 5000 residentes se vieron
obligados a abandonar sus casas la gente
está fuera de sí algunos han perdido a
su hijo a su hija o a su familia entera
que Dios se apiade de ellos
juro por Dios que no puedo dormir cada
vez que siento un pequeño movimiento me
acuerdo de todo el temblor
en Siria muchas infraestructuras
afectadas y débiles por la guerra civil
colapsaron una situación que las
organizaciones humanitarias calificaron
como una emergencia dentro de una
emergencia para lo que se necesita ayuda
internacional urgentemente
es desgarrador el daño y el impacto en
la gente de impacto
y acabamos de llegar hoy con algunos
suministros y ganas de seguir apoyando
países vecinos como emiratos árabes
Unidos ya enviaron equipos y se espera
que llegue más ayuda en los próximos
días miles de sirios se han quedado sin
una casa a la que volver y se han visto
obligados a buscar Refugio Naciones
Unidas y calificó los terremotos como el
peor acontecimiento ocurrido en la
región en un siglo teme que la cifra
final de víctimas en Siria y Turquía
rebase las 50.000 personas